hello and welcome to the
fifth php tutorial in this tutorial
we're going to get into
one of the more basic functionalities
of pretty much any programming language
you have like
if else statements and then you have
four and while loops
um that are pretty much in every single
language so
let's do the if statements
first and you you don't have to follow
if
with else um but you can
follow it with else but for now all
we're going to do
is show you a quick if
statement the syntax for an if statement
is you say
if and then in the in parentheses you
specify
whatever um the case that you're looking
for
is and then um what you
actually produce if that is the case is
within these curly braces
so um and with python
i'm not going to get too much too into
depth about this but
um they call this kind of like your
standards
and you could in theory code
everything on in one line you
or or like you wouldn't have to indent
but generally
what you do is every time you have like
a new um
statement of some sort or something
that's within a parent of something else
so in this case
whatever is encased in this if statement
like what you want to do
you would code it here and say stuff you
wouldn't want to encode it
here and say stuff so anyway
um we'll get more into that and i'm not
really or at least you'll see me using
these standards it's just a good idea to
get used to them because
for one for you to read your own code
and then also for
other people to ever read your code if
you're ever working with somebody
or if you have like a question nobody
wants to answer your question if your
standards are horrible and they can't
read your code
this is really just kind of a pain so
anyway keep that in mind
because like some languages like if
you're coming from python it just
automatically gives you beautiful
standards it doesn't request that you do
any of this
so if you're not used to it you'll just
have to start doing it
so let's do if and we'll do
name and then the way you do this is if
an irregular equal sign is an assignment
this is a double equal sign is a
comparison
so if name equals and we're going to say
harrison
um then we want to do something right
we've already said it equals harrison so
this will be the case
now you might also see and we'll go into
detail with this
um in another video but you might also
see
triple equals in the case of string data
it's not as
as useful as if like if we were doing
age
like if we had an if statement regarding
age you don't type this out with me i'm
just going to show you like if we did if
age equals
99 that means one thing
but if you said if age triple equals 99
this would be true
but if you said if age equals just 99
like the integer type
of data this would actually return a
false value but if you did if age
equals equals 99 it would return a true
so
double equals just tries to compare it
on you know
the value itself not data type but a
triple equals
is going to require the exact same data
type
so anyway just keep that in mind it
really doesn't matter in this case i'm
just going to use double
equals when you're comparing string data
it's not as big of an
issue unless it has you know numbers
within it
so we're going to say if name equals
harrison
now within this you can do this is where
you're going to code whatever you want
it to do so we're going to say
echo
and let's just have it echo strong
hello
and then close off our strong tags close
off our statement
and that's it so we'll save that
put it up on the server and actually
let's delete
this part so we don't see a bunch of
different code
and we'll refresh and obviously name did
equal harrison so it says of course
hello harrison